good morning john two days ago dan
howell uploaded a video called why i
quit youtube and the first half of it is
one of the most eloquent thoughtful and
in my opinion accurate takes on the
history of youtube and the many bad
parts of being a youtuber and there's
not much i can add to it like it's very
good i agree with everything in it which
is weird because i've talked to dan like
twice in my life also it's 85 minutes
long and we have a four minute time
limit but listening to a summation of
some of the worst parts of the last 15
years of my life did make me kind of
wonder why why didn't we quit why
haven't we burned out on this why didn't
we focus on some of the many other
things that we had to focus on and just
like
sorry youtube we're done certainly a lot
of other people have done that and i
respect that decision a lot like i
understand and i can't answer this
question for you john cause i think this
is very personal i think that different
people respond to all of this stuff very
differently but i can think back to the
times when i did kind of entertain the
idea of maybe quitting and it has been
because
the weight got too heavy for the support
that i had to carry and to get an idea
here are two of the the forms that that
wait has taken first feeling a
responsibility that i don't know that i
can live up to to be like
everyone's unproblematic king like to
not only be what i have attempted to say
that i am which is already a fairly high
standard but also to be what everyone is
imagining me to be which is of course
impossible because people imagine
different things like occasionally i
will say something on twitter that is
something that i have believed for a
long time like since high school and
people will be like wow man you've
changed and i'll be like yes i have i
have but not in that not that thing that
thing has been the same so that's hard
and one thing i think a lot about is
that like people have too many reasons
to kind of lose faith in the world right
now um and i the last thing i want to be
is one of them another form that the
weight can take is just having people
really dislike me and be mean to me on
the internet it's a thing that happens
it hasn't happened in a while but it has
happened and it's bad so in those
moments when it has been bad that has
made me feel like why am i doing this i
don't have the support necessary to
carry this weight and john i think that
we have been very lucky in both the
weight department like not carrying as
much as we might have if we got less
lucky or had different lives and in the
support department where we just have
good support good support which can be
both internal and external like i am my
own support but i have support around it
allows you to not just like handle the
weight when it's like sort of piling on
but to enjoy it when it's like an
appropriate amount because of course
some weight is good i want some
responsibility i want people to rely on
me i want to be held to a standard i
want to take what we have regardless of
whether we deserve it because what is
deserving and do the best things we can
with it that is what makes the weight
actually feel good
and that is i think why this community
has done so much different stuff over
the years we kind of shoulder it all
together and we do good things with it
like for example the awesome socks club
which has donated over a million dollars
to partners in health for our work in
sierra leone we have a short sign up
window open now if you want to check it
out there's a link in the description
every week i make a video it could be my
last video and i know a hundred percent
that everyone watching would be
supportive of me stepping away if i felt
like i had to i did not upload this
video today because i felt like i had to
i uploaded this video today because i
feel like our work here isn't done and i
don't know if i could have articulated
that before i watched a dan's video so
dan thank you for that after 15 years
because of your support and our parents
support and our friend support and
catherine and sarah's support and the
support of all the people we work with
at complexly and dftba and you know
hopefully by engaging thoughtfully in
what we are attempting to do it's not
like we don't talk about it a lot we
talk about it a lot we've been able to
continue creating together and the
weight has for the most part remained
healthy and the support for the most
part has remained strong how i'm feeling
after all that is just grateful to have
had the luck and the support that we
have without which to be certain we
would have gotten all these cool things
done and we would have quit
like that's absolutely true so to
everybody who's been a part of this
thank you um thank you thank you we're
very lucky john i'll see you on tuesday